welcome to the heavy spoilers show
i'm your host definition and this
episode we're breaking down the jordan
peel movie
us the film came hot off the heels of
peel's best picture nominee get out
and though it didn't quite achieve the
acclaim of its predecessor
there's still a lot to talk about in
regards to it the movie is filled to the
brim with little easter eggs and hidden
details that really make it an
interesting watch
throughout this video we'll be going
through the ins and outs of the film
including all of its meanings and
messages there will be heavy spoilers
here so if you haven't had a chance to
watch the film yet and don't want
anything ruined then i highly recommend
that you turn off now
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day
and if you enjoy it then please drop a
thumbs up without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown
of us okay so us follows adelaide wilson
a woman who goes on vacation with a
family to their holiday home in santa
cruz
upon arriving there adelaide becomes
haunted by a memory
in which a doppelganger attacked her in
a fun house when she was a child
she initially just seems paranoid but
her worst fears are realized when a
duplicate of her family attacks them in
the home at night
these are the tethered and slowly the
copies of humanity have started an
uprising
they are led by the copy of adelaide
known as red
and she becomes the main antagonist of
the film the family fight to survive
and eventually the youngest of the group
jason is kidnapped by red
adelaide descends into a secret door
hidden within the fun house
and she finds the home of the tethered
below it here she kills red
and rescues jason but it's revealed in
the end that adelaide was actually the
original doppelganger and that she
switched places with red
taking her life in the process that's a
basic plot summary just in case you
haven't seen it
but there's quite a lot going on in the
movie now before going through
everything we need to discuss the
significance of the number 11
which appears throughout the film at
several points this is actually a
reference to jeremiah
chapter and verse 11 11 from the king
james bible
and in that the following passage can be
found therefore thus saith the lord
behold i will bring evil upon them which
they shall not be able to escape
and though they shall cry unto me i will
not hearken unto them
this basically discusses red's quest and
how she wishes to bring doom to the
surface dwellers
now why the number itself is also
important is because
11 is a palindrome a number that is the
same forward as it is back
it's a complete reflection of itself and
this symbolism of a mirror is given
further weight by
11 11 once more reflecting the 11's and
so on and so on and so on we're going to
be saying
11 a lot in this video there's also a
lot of mirroring going on in the film
and the wilsons themselves can be seen
as somewhat of a reflection
as there are two males in the family and
two females
two adults two children and generally
there's this idea of mirroring that is
seen within them
and their tethered copies things above
the ground are mirrored by those below
and throughout the piece elements line
up and are seen as almost complete
reflections
as for the film itself mirroring and
this idea of 11
is seen throughout we open with a news
report on channel 11 news
with a report that will happen on 11 at
11. we can see
a reflection of adelaide in the screen
and an advertisement for hands across
america plays in this we can see the
twin towers
which look like the number 11 and then
we see two women running on a beach
them being 11 and their reflections
being 11 as well and
it's a lot of elevens hands across
america was about people putting their
hands across the country
and this could hold the meaning of the
tethered binding themselves once more to
each other
rather than those that they are copies
of the film is very much about the
oppressed
and forgotten rising up and taking their
place in society
and even the title us was purposely
chosen to stand for united states
in the film red says we are americans
when they're asked who they are
and i definitely think this ties in
together next to the tv
are four video tapes each of which looks
like a number one
in a way which once more hammers home
this point of 11
11. take a shot every time i say 11 by
the way i'm just kidding
you'll be dead in the next 11 seconds
anyway one of those video types is chud
or rather the movie cannibalistic
humanoid underground dwellers which is a
reference to the tethered rising from
the underground we then jump to the
santa cruz fair
and adelaide asks for prize number 11
which just so happens to be a michael
jackson thriller t-shirt
peel said he intentionally chose michael
jackson here because
as a child he viewed him as a
larger-than-life positive figure
that too had the ability to scare him
because of his thriller video
throughout the film red also wears one
glove which could be a reference to the
pop icon
adelaide and her parents walk through
the fair and they discuss a movie being
filmed by the carousel
this is a reference to the vampire
classic the lost boys which was filmed
at the same location
peel also picked this because of the two
quarries that feature in the film
corey haynes and corey feldman and
adelaide's father buys two tickets for
whack-a-mole
and two fairground tickets side by side
look like uh
i'll not say adelaide walks towards the
beach where she sees a man holding a
jeremiah 11 11
sign and there are two people playing
rock paper scissors
they constantly mirror one another
choosing the exact same thing
which just so happens to be scissors two
pair of finger scissors look like 11
11 and scissors of course are the weapon
used by red throughout the film
the scissors that red uses look like two
heads back to back
and they mirror each other perhaps
signifying two people
the fun house has a sign that says find
yourself which adelaide does
and the voice of the announcer in the
location is jordan peele
adelaide whistles the itsy bitsy spider
which is about a spider climbing up a
drainpipe
and this is meant to symbolize red
coming from the bottom
or adelaide i get confused a real spider
crawls out from under a fake one on a
coffee table
and at one point in the film red moves
her fingers on her face in a spider leg
motion
before the twist is revealed at the end
red also whistles the itsy bitsy spider
just before she dies which highlights
that she is in fact the real one
we then cut to the title sequence which
contains rabbits within cages
and these are in rows of 11. amongst the
white and brown ones there's also a
black one who looks slightly out of
place
field said he put this in place
deliberately to show that the real
adelaide was now trapped below with the
tethered we then cut to the wilsons in
their car
and a sticker on the rear window of four
people can be seen
this follows the format of 11 11 layout
wise
and it's also how the tethered family
show up on the driveway
jason is wearing a jaws t-shirt and the
image which is taken from the poster is
of a fish coming from the depths
and rising to the surface to claim its
prey zora is wearing a rabbit shirt
which of course
ties the animals that are laced
throughout the film gabe does a knock
knock joke that goes
knock knock who's there you you who
open up the door which whilst it's a
proper dad joke
it's also a reference to how you will be
at the door
which of course happens when the
tethered show up in their house is a
picture of adelaide
and her mother who is wearing all red
and rising above adelaide
perhaps showing the rising of red jason
says if you point a finger at someone
you get three fingers pointing back at
you which gabe then corrects
three plus one is four four fingers look
like 11
11 look we'll get it anyway from here we
get another look at adelaide's childhood
in a sandbox she lines animals up one by
one
side by side and places a white rabbit
in between them
this could be seen as representing the
hands across america
and it may hint at red planning to be at
the center of it
adelaide's parents also say that she
cannot speak which hints at her being
one of the tethered
rather than simply suffering from shock
at the home adelaide finds a bunny in a
box
and she smiles when she looks at it
perhaps recalling her childhood in the
tunnels
this doll later gets its head cut off by
red who sees it as a sign of contempt
jason puts an ambulance in the door to
stop it closing and this could be a
reference to the ambulance that they
drive off in at the end
when they close all this behind them the
ambulance has
11 11 written on the top of it and this
call back here is a nice bit of
foreshadowing
on the ride to the beach zora brings up
a fluoride conspiracy theory
in which he says that the government has
placed it in the water to control
people's minds
this sounds crazy at first but we later
learned that the entire tethered program
was put in place
in an attempt to control humanity
through their copies
they play i've got five on it on the
radio and adelaide tries to click along
with it
but she's out of time showcasing that
the tethered have trouble with rhythm
and it shows that she's just slightly
out of sync which is a nod to the twist
peels say that he chose this song for
the trailer because it shows the darker
side that can exist within people
most notably in their youth gabe says
it's a dope song
but we know what the song is really
about and this could highlight he wasn't
always the upstanding father that we see
in the film
i think this may be reflected in
adelaide too who as we know has a dark
side to her past
in the car they passed the man with the
jeremiah 11 11 sign from the start of
the film
and he has had 11 11 carved into his
chest
this foreshadows that things from
adelaide's past will come back together
but it also shows why the man's
duplicate who we later see
on the beach has blood dripping from his
hands the adelaides walk along the beach
and their shadows look like 11 11 once
more
the family are also in line with each
other except for adelaide who isn't
hinting that she perhaps isn't in line
with the rest of them
here they meet another family known as
the tylers
kitty discusses her facelift and we
later see that her copy has scars on her
face
likely because in the underground it was
carried out by a surgeon with scissors
one of the twins also has a t-shirt that
looks like 11
11 and the pair mimic each other's
speech completely at one point
showing mirroring once more a red
frisbee lands on a blue circle
perfectly symbolizing reds rising and
taking over
and this red over the top of blue could
also be a call back to the painting from
earlier
in jason's room we can see a picture
that looks like people holding hands
referencing the hands across america and
gabe watches the highlights of a game on
the tv
in this there was an 11 11 tie in the
seventh inning
and in jason's room the clock hits 11 11
i'm getting sick of this now
adelaide tells a story to gabe about her
doppelganger in which she clicks
slightly when speaking
perhaps hinting at her hidden history
she does this whilst looking at her
reflection in glass
mirroring the story of the doppelganger
discovery which too
involved coming face to face with her
reflection anyway
the tethers show up and gabe warns them
that the police
they already on their way the wilsons
did call them
but as we know the world is in chaos so
they don't show up
red arrives whistling the itsy bitsy
spider and she's able to gain access to
the house through a key that was hidden
under a rock
this shows that she has been to the
property before and that
she is the real one red is also the only
member of the tethered able to speak
whereas the others make clicks and yell
because they didn't live in an
environment where they were able to
learn things through someone else
this is how babies learn to talk but the
fact that red can do it
also shows that she learned this on the
outside world red has difficulty talking
at first because she hasn't done it in a
while
and she tells the story of the two
tethered shadows she discusses how the
underground operates
and how they were forced to eat rabbits
there are also some interesting
character traits too
for example abraham isn't able to see
because
in the underground he wasn't able to get
the glasses that gabe has ombre was born
laughing which juxtaposes zoro's shy
personality
and she's also able to run a lot faster
than zora is
because she ran on hard concrete and
tiles where zora
ran on tracks and so on ombre is the
plural form of shadow
highlighting that she is the shadow side
of zora
zora also changes into a hoodie that has
thor written on it
which is vietnamese for rabbit no no
doubt you've you've heard that a million
times
on breakdowns better than this the
tethered attack the family
and they all kind of break off from one
another i love when pluto unmasks and
shows his burnt face
and i was trying to think of where i
knew it from or what the reference was
and shout outs to reddit for pointing
out that it's like when jason voorhees
and masks on friday the 13th
in friday the 13th as well jason's
mother was also revealed as the villain
similar to how adelaide is at the end in
fiction pluto is also referred to as the
lord of the underworld
once more tying back to things being
underground anyway
the group all reunite and manage to
escape to the tilers
however bad things happen there and we
actually see the full attack carried out
by the tethered
the twins appear together at the top of
the stairs looking like an 11
and then they are joined by their copies
who appear like 11
11 before taking their place kitty calls
out for her alexa like device named
ophelia to call for the police
but instead it plays after police by nwa
the opening of this song contains a line
that says f the police coming straight
from the underground
which could be a reference to the
tethered coming from the underground
ophelia also means help in greek which
is what kitty is trying to get
the wilsons arrive at the house and papa
teller doesn't
immediately attack adelaide who goes to
the door first this is possibly because
he can sense her and he believes that
she's red
another interesting moment also happens
with the tethered version of kitty in
the bedroom
in which she vainly looks at her
reflection whilst trying on makeup
kitty had a facelift possibly because
she was vain and it's likely that her
copy has had to go through this motion
numerous times
she even cuts her own face possibly
because she believes that this is a sign
of beauty
she also goes to kill adelaide but lets
her live showing that red instructed her
to do this
so she could draw out the revenge plot
this is likely why the tylers were
killed instantly
whereas the wilsons weren't gabe flees
the tyler's boat
and we can see that it's bigger and
better than his one he did mention that
they were constantly trying to one-up
the family
and this can be seen by the fact that
they have this whereas the wilson's one
barely works
the family then watch a news report
which is once more on channel 11
and it's here we get the first hint of
the hands across america
this was a big thing from adelaide's
childhood and clearly the publicity it
got stuck with her
which is likely what influenced her to
instruct the tether to do it
adelaide also wants to flee to mexico
and i don't know if i'm reaching here
but if
us stands for united states then the
underside of that is south america
and mexico perhaps suggesting moving
from the top to the bottom
adelaide is attacked by another one of
the tethered but she kills them
which jason stumbles across and adelaide
pants similar to them
foreshadowing the twist eventually they
make it to the beach and come face to
face with pluto
pluto waits until adelaide is out of the
car before almost sparking the fire
but jason is able to read his mind and
get the family out
jason is able to control him and make
him walk into the fire
perhaps showing that the mind control
experiment did work
but that the government couldn't get it
to operate properly on the end of the
tethered
red snatches jason and flees at the fun
house where she's chased by adelaide who
sees hands stretching across the beach
even into the ocean this means that some
of the tethered drown themselves in
doing this
we can see the tethered version of the
man that was holding the sign has also
carved 11 11 into his head
now you may have noticed at this point
the adelaide's clothes are almost red
from all of the blood
this could be a nod to the upcoming
reveal as they transition
from white to red in the basement
adelaide confronts red
and she cuts out some people holding
hands these are similar to the family
sticker on the car
and also an 11 11 symbol she cuts these
down to just two
symbolizing an 11 and then splits them
completely to show the antenna ring
also when we see a flashback the
escalator from the ground up
to looks like 11 11. we get the
backstory and adelaide is actually able
to recall this herself
because it happened for her we see that
the tethered all mimic those above
and one of the big questions that i've
seen floating about the movie is
how did they break free of the control
that those above had well i believe that
they
simply didn't think that they had it and
therefore didn't ever try to untether
themselves
however during the ballet performance
they see that red is able to do
different moves to adelaide
and realize that they have free will the
fight begins
and i love how red's moves are very
square and deliberate because she's had
to exist in tunnels filled with
rectangular corridors
adelaide kills her and she whistles the
itsy bitsy spider with her last breath
with her son she escapes to the surface
and we get the revelation that she
switched places
jason clearly knows this and has
realized but coming to the conclusion
himself that he is half tethered too
he decides to lower the mask and hide
behind it
signifying the lie about his mother's
past will be kept a secret
also there's what looks like an 11 11 on
the thriller t-shirt
in the flashback i'm sorry i swear
that's the last one adelaide at the end
smiles at jason after the reveal which
could be a nod to the ending of the
thriller music video
and that concludes the breakdown now
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on it
and if there's anything we missed make
sure you comment below and let us know
and if you enjoyed the video then please
leave a like as it massively helps us
out
and make sure you check out our
breakdown of jordan peels get out which
is going to be linked at the end
every month on the 15th we give away
free blu-rays and all you have to do to
begin with the chance of winning the
marvel phase 3.1 box set is leave a like
and subscribe with notifications on
if you want to support the channel and
get to see content early then please
consider clicking the join button
you can also come chat to us on our
discord server linked below or at
definition yt on twitter
those are the best ways to keep up to
date with the channel so hopefully we
see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe huge thank you for taking the
time to watch this
i've been definition you've been the
best and i'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you